March 10 was bonus day for the 8,000 employees
of Silicon Valley Bank.
They got their bonus that Friday.
Hours later, the bank failed.
On Monday, customers could be seen lining
up to try to retrieve their funds.
Silicon Valley Bank was the bank of choice
for thousands of companies in the tech sector
- many of them startups fueled by angel investors.
Almost half of all venture capital funding
in the United States flowed through the bank
at one time or another.
And then, suddenly, it all came to an end.
The speed at which things unraveled caught
many by surprise – even the bank’s CEO.
A few weeks before the collapse, CEO Greg
Becker told CNBC that the future looked good.
“What we are expecting to see in 2023, first
half, actually in venture capital, actually
a little bit more of a decline even than what
we saw in the fourrth quarter.
But the second half was going to kind of create
that modest improvement and really set the
stage for a better 2024.
So, we’re optimistic because our crystal
ball is a little clearer than it was in the
third quarter last year.”
Perhaps his crystal ball wasn’t shiny enough
to predict the future.
Startups struggled to raise additional venture
capital due to the current economic environment.
So, they began withdrawing more and more of
their cash from their SVB accounts.
The bank had the money – in theory – but
it wasn’t sitting in a vault waiting to
be handed back to its customers.
You’re thinking of this all wrong as if
I had the money back in the safe.
The money’s not here.
The bank had invested the money in Treasury
bonds, a type of government debt, in which
the government borrows money and pays it back
with interest.
When customers started pulling their money
out of the bank, SVB had no choice but to
start selling the bonds at a discount so they
could get enough cash to satisfy customer
demand.
Becker decided to publicly announce that the
bank had sold off $2 1 billion in bonds.
But those bonds weren't worth as much as they
used to be because the Fed kept raising interest
rates.
When interest rates go up, bond prices usually
go down.
This is because new bonds have higher interest
rates, so people prefer them over older bonds.
Think of it like this: Imagine you have a
candy store and sell a candy for $1.
This candy gives the buyer a little 10-cent
surprise each year.
If another store sells a similar candy for
the same price but offers a 15-cent surprise
each year, people would choose to buy candy
from the other store instead.
So the bank had to sell its older bonds at
lower prices, which ultimately led to a loss
of $1.8 billion.
While Becker hoped to raise more than that
in new capital, he said he still had not found
anyone willing to help the bank ride out the
storm.
Perhaps he was looking to be transparent,
but it backfired.
Big time.
CNN quotes an anonymous bank employee as saying:
“That was absolutely idiotic…their transparency
and forthrightness did them in.”
The extent of the bank’s financial troubles
panicked customers, leading to a phenomenon
called a bank run, where everyone starts taking
their money out of the bank all at once.
The next day, customers withdrew $42 billion
from their accounts, leaving SVB with a negative
cash balance of $958 million.
And, public filings show Becker himself cashed
out personal shares and options worth $2 million
dollars just before the collapse!
The day the bank failed, Becker told employees,
“I’m not making the decisions anymore.”
This is the second largest bank failure in
US history, behind only the collapse of Washington
Mutual at the height of the subprime mortgage
crisis in 2008.
And then, the third largest bank failure in
U.S. history happened on SVB’s heels.
Two days later, on March 12, regulators shut
down Signature Bank in New York to prevent
the crisis from spreading through the entire
financial system.
A quarter of Signature Bank’s deposits came
from the cryptocurrency sector.
But, regulators denied it closed the bank
because of its large hand in crypto and, rather,
cited what it called “a significant crisis
of confidence in the bank’s leadership”.
The question now is: are there more bank failures
to come?
They are more common than people think.
Few people are old enough to remember the
2,293 banks that collapsed in 1931, a development
that led to the Great Depression.
But there have been more than 500 since the
collapse of Washington Mutual in 2008, although
most pale in comparison to the size of SVBs.
Mark Williams, a former bank examiner for
the Federal Reserve, told Boston University’s
daily news website BU Today, “If not quelled,
bank runs can spread like wildfire, crippling
even the soundest of banks.”
To quell further panic, President Biden quickly
assured Americans.
“Americans can have confidence that the
banking system is safe.
Your deposits will be there when you need
them.”
In the U.S., deposits in a bank are insured
by the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation
or FDIC up to $250,000.
However, over 90% of deposits at SVB exceeded
that amount.
The federal government then jumped in to guarantee
deposits greater than $250,000.
And, the Federal Reserve also said it would
make additional emergency funds available
to eligible financial institutions to prevent
similar problems in the future.
Billionaire hedge fund investor, Bill Ackman,
made a point of saying:
“Had [U.S. regulators] not intervened today,
we would have had a 1930s bank run continuing
first thing Monday causing enormous economic
damage and hardship to millions.”
However, Ackman also warned: “More banks
will likely fail despite the intervention”.
There’s little doubt that the Fed is partly
to blame for SVB’s stunning collapse.
Over the past year, the Federal Reserve has
been aggressively hiking interest rates to
tame inflation by making borrowing more expensive,
which slows down spending and keeps prices
from rising too quickly.
And in the process, SVB got caught in the
undertow.
Former U.S. Treasury Secretary Larry Summers
criticized regulators and also the bank’s
management.
“And I have to say that it doesn’t appear
on current facts that a very good job was
done about regulating and supervising Silicon
Valley Bank.
It had committed kind of the most elementary
errors, in borrowing money in a very short
term way and then investing it in a long-term
way, and then when interest rates went up,
those assets lost their value.”
Some are blaming wokeness for the bank’s
demise, implying that the collapse was related
to the company’s focus on diversity and
inclusion.
A Wall Street Journal opinion columnist wrote:
"I'm not saying 12 white men would have avoided
this mess, but the company may have been distracted
by diversity demands"
The best outcome for the failed bank is for
U.S. officials to find a buyer.
There will be no bailout…which typically
uses taxpayer dollars to keep the bank afloat.
Biden does not want to reignite the anger
from the 2008 Wall Street bailouts that were
funded by taxpayers, especially with a presidential
election approaching.
The collapse of Silicon Valley Bank brings
up memories of another President who took
office in 1933 when banks were going under
almost daily.
During his inaugural address, President Franklin
D. Roosevelt famously urged people not to
panic.
“Let me assert my firm belief that the only
thing we have to fear is fear itself—nameless,
unreasoning, unjustified terror which paralyzes
needed efforts to convert retreat into advance.”
It appears that 90 years later, Roosevelt's
wise counsel has been largely ignored.
Financial stocks have now lost a combined
$465 billion in just one weekend.
But will it be the last disaster?
This crash was caused in part by the Fed raising
rates - which they may still be committed
to.
JP Morgan says the S&P 500 could sink another
20% as the economy is pushed to the brink.
So big institutions like them are going big
into alternative assets
One alternative asset rose an average of 29%
last year, handily beating stocks: fine art
Masterworks offers fully investible art from
legends like Picasso,
Which are qualified with the SEC, and broken
into shares - so you don't need millions of
dollars to invest.
In fact, each of their 11 exits to date has
returned a profit.
As a result, paintings have sold out in hours,
not days
But right now you can get priority access
to skip the wait list below.